por eso conectamos con nuestro
corresponsal en washington cristóbal
vázquez cristóbal lo saludo y le
pregunto primero cuáles son las
principales temas sobre los que ha sido
cuestionada la jueza nominada y que ha
respondido de ella
pues ella ha sido muy enfática diciendo
que es una jurista independiente sin
embargo esto no ha calmado las
acusaciones o cuestionamientos de
republicanos que la cuestiona sobre todo
por haber defendido prisioneros de
guerra cuando en la en la prisión de
guantánamo prisión estadounidense en
cuba en esta prisión a muchos organismos
de derechos humanos dicen que estos
prisioneros no tuvieron el debido
proceso y que algunos de ellos fueron
puesto a tu lado si eso fue lo que
defendió la juez nominada que tansy
brawn jackson ella también ha resaltado
el tema de su defensa en casos de
pornografía infantil y cuando se le
preguntó por ejemplo sobre el tema del
aborto ella dijo que pues simplemente
acata las decisiones que ya la corte
suprema de justicia ha tomado sobre el
tema pero se nota sin embargo esta
división esta polarización entre
republicanos y demócratas republicanos
que tratan de cuestionar precisamente
esas posiciones personales de ellas a
favor o en defensa de los prisioneros de
guerra en guantánamo y los la estás
defendiendo lo que haya hecho en el
pasado
cristóbal cómo será entonces este
proceso de confirmación cuando podríamos
saber si finalmente la confirman como
jueza de la corte suprema
yo bailé la nominó hace unas semanas el
proceso de confirmación empezó ayer con
testimonios iniciales hoy y mañana
tendrán será el período de preguntas 22
senadores de el comité judicial del
senado tendrán 30 minutos cada uno para
hacer sus respectivas preguntas esas son
audiencias que durarán casi hasta 12
horas en las que que tan si brawn
jackson tendrá que responder a estos 22
senadores y ya el jueves será el turno
de testigos que conocen agitan y brawn
jackson y que respaldan su trabajo el
presidente del comité judicial del
senado richard durbin dijo que quiere
confirmar a la juez a la primera
afroamericana en la corte suprema de
justicia antes del 8 de abril es decir
antes de el receso de pascua